so we launched it today it's called
business boutique equipping women to
make money doing what they love it's
Christy right leading this charge
Rachael Cruz will be speaking stephanie
parker the creator of zip Zippity zip my
buddy Cordy cordilla harrington the CEO
and founder of the bun companies
affectionately known as the bun lady
Tiffany Peterson will be speaking on
selling and marketing shannon linton the
president CEO of 5x5 marketing agency
and other marketing Mari Smith a social
media expert literally is hired by
Facebook to teach how to use Facebook
she's one of the top in the nation
coming to this LA hokum we'll be doing
singing and praising worship and leading
a devotional with us and Jeremy Cowart
will be one of the top photographers on
the Internet we'll be there there's
going to be breakout sessions on
marketing on taxes on accounting we're
going to do a two-day thing equipping
women to make money doing what they love
Christie Wright has been with me this
hour it's exciting time for us you can
get your tickets at business boutique
calm or Dave Ramsey calm or you can call
triple-a 22-piece there are only $99 a
person you can get two seats for a
hundred and seventy five Kristi going of
the break we said the number one problem
they fit that these ladies facing this
situation is time management what's
number two probably money figuring out
how to interact with money they have
this love/hate relationship with money
and so it's interesting to see how some
of them are motivated by wanting to stay
home with their kids they want to
contribute to the family income but then
at the same time they're conflicted
because they feel guilty charging or
they have friends that ask for something
free or at cost and so they feel like
they need to take care of them and so
they're really having trouble not only
just breaking even which is hurting
their family budget but also making a
profit and understanding the inherent
goodness of business and the goodness of
making a profit and serving the
marketplace and so you're really seeing
the struggle so we're gonna head on
money hard at this event to really help
them understand not only the necessity
of making money in profit but the
goodness of it the goodness of doing
business well when you do business well
you're the profit is the applause
customers give you Ken Blanchard says
and Rabbi lapin talks about it and thou
shall prosper that when you do do when
you serve that your customers give you
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces writing them right and
you should accept the certificate and
you've done nothing wrong but there's a
shame or a guilt about that as if I'm
somehow I'm doing this for the passion
I'm not doing this for the money right
and there's a separation there isn't
there well I hear them say interesting
things too like well I enjoy it so much
I feel guilty charging like you
shouldn't make money because you're
having a good time when you're painting
or sewing or whatever the the skill or
craft your business is around they also
feel guilty charging because many of
them don't value it themselves well it's
so easy for me well I don't I mean it's
not that good of a painting and so I'm
nobody would probably want to pay for
this so they have a little bit of a
struggle with a belief in it and belief
in the business and the product themself
so of course you communicate that to the
marketplace and then you're teaching
people what your value is and what the
what the product is worth sometimes
you're just charged enough they think
it's valuable
all right crystals with us in Las Vegas
crystal your question for Christie right
thanks for taking my call my husband and
I want to start a family within the next
year but I'm concerned how to keep my
business alive directly after giving
birth I have a home-based business I
serve as a virtual assistant and I have
a very loyal recurring client base and
however I don't have enough retained
earnings to feel comfortable hiring an
assistant to take over in in a maybe a
short term absence after giving birth
well I would say there's a real there's
something very genuine whenever you just
share your heart with people and so if
you if you were to communicate to your
client base right now I know you said
you have a client base and let them know
your plans and your intentions of I'm
planning to start a family and here's my
plan for maternity leave here's what my
schedule will look like here's what I'll
be we'll be back you can provide some
solutions for them of either referral in
the meantime but then say I would love
your business when you come back but for
you if it's important for you to have a
maternity leave for you to take that
time off then simply communicating that
to your client base you may lose a few
but a lot of times when you're honest
and upfront and especially around
something so beautiful and wonderful of
starting a small business or I'm sorry
starting a family then a lot of times
the business will still be there a lot
of times the people will kind of stay
with you through that because they
understand it
like I said we're in a relational
business here and so a lot of times if
you build that relationship then if
you've served them well they'll still be
there it's different than a corporate
job where you do Family Leave Act and
that kind of I mean you and Rachel just
both went through that right this year
right both of you having the baby and I
noticed with both of you because you're
very much self-employed working here
right I mean you as speakers as
personalities you guys have things you
have to you just can't lay it down for
12 whole weeks right and so you guys are
not working full-time yet right still
way after normal maternity leave right
but in return what happened was your
first couple weeks after the birth was
very intense and is completely silent
and then you started rien gauging
gradually right during what would have
been a normal maternity leave right
maybe that would work well not do what
we planned ahead and I don't know if
this would work for your business with
being a virtual assistant if people need
things on a week-by-week basis but
something that I manage regularly is my
social media and my blog content my
videos and so what I did during the
months of November to January was I shot
a ton of videos that wrote a ton of
blogs I planned a ton of social and I
had those scheduled to go out even when
I was at home with my baby covered you
know in burp cloths and wearing yoga
pants so things were still happening in
the marketplace representing my brands I
directed the exact same yes and I don't
know if that would work for your for
your business with virtual being a
virtual assistant if there is work you
could do ahead of time or schedule for
your clients that would probably help as
well for you to give a little get a
little bit of leave jessica is in Des
Moines Iowa hi Jessica how are you good
how are you better than I deserve your
question for Christi well first of all
days you're awesome that's all I have to
say about that Christy um I am a female
hunter and I really enjoy hunting my
husband and I go quite a few places and
I'm a lot of times the only female and
for the longest time I wanted to do
white Caesar a blog or even an article
magazine every month and I want to call
it ladies and lanyards and lanyard
that's what I love it because I I have a
lot of stories about being the only
female and you know sometimes some of
the issues that we have that the men
don't or don't worry about and about
being a female hunter and I
you know I'm not good with technology I
mean I can write essays all day and
write things but I don't know like where
I would start to get maybe a blog or
even if you think's getting into a
magazine would be better I'm not even
worried about the money part
I just want to empower other women you
know that that are trying to determine
thing and maybe Intimidators no sir
absolutely it's very cool that is very
cool so I think the first this good
starting point would be your blog you
need to have some writing samples before
you would be brought in to you know to
write for a magazine for example most
likely so you want to have some some
writing samples you know you really
there needs to be a strategy for your
blog though anybody can start a blog and
a lot of the blog's out there there's
billions of blogs they don't have a
strategy they just it's random stories
and there's rambling etc so I would
really encourage you to kind of map out
just a strategy it can be very simple it
doesn't have to be complicated why do
you want to start a blog I think you
said you want to empower other women so
that's a great statement I want to start
this blog to empower other women and
then and then what do you you know what
are you kind of driving towards so if
your blogs are going to be around
specific to the hunting business or just
women in non-traditional industries or
how you want to structure it just
mapping out a little bit of strategy on
the front end will really help you build
it the platform and physically creating
a blog is not hard you know there's
templates out there that make it super
easy for you to do even if you didn't
want to do it yourself with a like a
wordpress template or something that's
available to you you could find someone
that would easily you know a teenager in
a garage or someone that you know in
your community or church I'm sure that
you could barter with or pay a little
bit of money and they would get it up
and running for you but you really just
want to have a strategy before you start
writing because if not it can easily
become cluttered and and your audience
doesn't know what to draw readers in or
should go get her readers well you're
going to when you start with your
community you start with your your
community whether that's social media
are you on social media I got it on hold
okay so you'll start with social media
and then you'll start you know with your
community that your immediate networks
and you start putting it out there and
letting people know okay I'm doing this
blog I'm doing this thing and let them
share it with you but your content has
to be good I mean that's really key for
your blog to be successful there's a lot
of ownership we agreed I would tweet
links
hunting celebrities whoever that is I
don't know who that is but men gun
people and that kind of stuff tweet
links in because if guys picked that up
and read it they would hand it to their
wife and go you know hey read this come
with you you know that point exactly
exactly
I mean that could be a dream come true
for a lot of folks so very cool Christy
writes been our guest this half-hour
this exciting it is congratulation to
you it's gonna be big it's huge the
tickets are already well hanging out the
door I knew they would but this is
amazing you guys thank you for the
response the the event is called
business boutique it's November 6th and
7th in Nashville a whole lineup of
speakers business boutique calm you can
check it out at Dave Ramsey comm it's
$99 a person that's the early bird price
if you get it early now this is
equipping women to make money doing what
they love
talk about huge this is an economic
force we're getting rid unleash baby
here we go I love it this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you